j'ai quelques questions à vous poser
coûte et si ça peut vous faire gagner du
temps
j'ai bu plus de 30000 verre d'alcool
je ne marche pas c'est quand je mange et
je glisse doucement vers la quarantaine
vous avez des antécédents des problèmes
héréditaire ou bien je suis une femme
[Musique]
pour les filles on sent que chercher les
embrouilles ce soir
je voulais ce message n'est pas notre
place on est trop vieille pour étudier
leur trône raquette en corner
nous y oblige et de lâcheté est d'accord
la toile au couteau me sens prête à
repartir à zéro
j'en ai marre de vendre du vin j'ai
rendez vous avec le responsable des maux
corconne forte magazine c'est juste du
fable
mon copain d toujours que j'ai l'air
d'avoir centre
non j'ai l'impression mais courir après
grand paumé mais doucement il ya encore
deux semaines j'avais tout ce qu'il
fallait pour être heureuse alors il
nommé offre je me disais que je pourrais
venir à longue et lente ça c'est si mal
passé il a accepté la rupture avec
classe et
on est adulte
j'en sortirai plus jamais avec un mec je
serais pas en train de passer à côté de
ma ville langat landes c'est temporaire
c'est le slogan officiel de langue
island je vais vous dire vous êtes une
commercial hors pair mais vous devez
trouver ce qui vous passionne vraiment
je viens découvrir votre activité voilà
la grande partie qui peut accueillir il
s'assurerait cole qui parle a dit un
truc que j'aurais dû récolter ce sont
mes amis
sens bien ici comment il s'appelle c'est
elle leur donne pas de nom ou délicieux
du foie de la princesse du l'appart pour
ça que leur donne pas de nom
faut que je trouve ma voix et je pense
que je suis fait pour coach allez les
filles tout en place je suis désolé
[Musique]
je laime beaucoup mais j'ai passé trop
de temps avec des mecs qui étaient pas
pour moi et je le serai parfois la
douleur de l'esprit se manifestent
physiquement
j'ai décidé de suivre mon instinct et de
faire ce que je veux vraiment je reste
mais juste pour être sûr qu'il va pas tu
assassines tube hamas à sa merde bonjour
montrer venez je vais tuer personne
le réchauffement climatique c'est trop
triste mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
arrêter d'acheter des bouteilles en
plastique
celle là on me l'a offerte